[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
chilling new video release as the
accused sarah lauren's sex call leader
stands trial in federal court i wanted
to poison you
[Music]
and i didn't care about other people
plus is it fair to say that this isn't a
situation that you really that you
really want
no is this difficult who would the state
may soon rest his case as more family
members of alleged victims testify
against a former icu doctor charged with
the murder of his patients and dueling
lawsuits in the jesse smallett hoax
attack the accused attackers moved
forward with a defamation lawsuit as
smaller attorneys fired back but first a
verdict is handed down for the man
accused of murdering nba player lorenzen
wright you're sharing right
you decided to kill your husband
who were you going to get to help you
your friend baby lover
billy turner
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin after less than three hours of
deliberation a jury hands down the
verdict in the trial of slain basketball
player lorenzen wright
it's villa ray turner stand please sir
this vertebrae's as follows
state of tennessee versus billy ray
turner docket number one seven zero five
eight eight one count one
first degree murder
we the jury
find the defendant guilty of first
degree murder is charged in count one of
the indictment
count two conspiracy to commit
first-degree murder
the verdigris follows we the jury find
the defendant guilty of conspiracy to
commit first-degree murders charged in
count two of the indictments count three
criminal attempt first degree murder
the verdigrises follows we the jury find
the defendant guilty of criminal attempt
first degree murder as charged in count
three of the indictment and this verdict
and jacket is signed by the four person
for that verdict turner will receive
life in prison which amounts to 60 years
in the state of tennessee but he could
be eligible for release after 51 years
judge lee coffey announced turner will
be sentenced for the two other accounts
within 45 days all this stems from the
2010 murder of nba player lorenzen
wright turner was arrested seven years
after wright's body was found and the
murder weapon was recovered from a
mississippi lake in closing arguments
prosecutors point to the finger at
wright's ex-wife shara wright who they
say recruited turner to kill her
ex-husband they argued she was after the
basketball player's life insurance
payout
the written on 1-800 hitman hotline
so if you're sharing right
you decide to kill your husband
who are you going to get to help you
can't just go down to home depot and ask
around for murderers
maybe you ask your cousin
people from church
maybe somebody you trust
maybe somebody that's at your house all
the time
someone per his statement you've had sex
with at least once
someone you've had phone contact with
186 times during a 30-day period that
works out to about a little over six
times a day
who do you trust who you're going to get
to help you
your friend baby lover
billy turner
in in summation the defense argued the
state had not met his burden of proving
the case beyond a reasonable doubt
what we wanted to show
is his demeanor you look at him and you
see and say
and make your decision on whether or not
this guy eating ice cream and cake with
his church folks is in a few hours gonna
sit up and meet this guy on a dark road
and kill him
has anybody
gotten you passed
unlikely
has anybody
got you passed
maybe not
has anybody got you passed perhaps
perhaps billy did it because he loaned
his car for a couple of weeks
perhaps he
he he wanted to facilitate a murder
without there being any
conversation from the or testimony
rather from the witness stand saying
that he agreed that he wanted this man
killed
all right perhaps my good friend and
friend of the network forensic death
investigator joseph scott morgan and
terry oscar can shed light on this
verdict joseph there was a lot of
forensics in this case from a gun and a
lake to an autopsy but which piece of
forensics evidence stuck out to you as
the most important in terms of
incriminating evidence
well i think that it's probably going to
be this weapon that was recovered from
the lake
and putting it into the hand of one of
the confederates in this in this
particular conspiracy you know at the
end of the day when those rounds are
recovered and you can tie those
projectiles back to that specific weapon
that admittedly was used in the
commission of this homicide i think
that's a damning bit of information you
couple that
with the electronic evidence relative to
uh you know phone phone records and all
this sort of thing
it's it's a it's a really steep steep
mountain for the defense to climb
they're fair to say it would probably be
the smoking gun in the case
yeah now you're right terry what was
your reaction to the verdict and did you
expect it to come this fast
you know what brian i was not surprised
by the guilty verdict but i was a little
surprised that it took so quick to make
that decision there was a lot of
evidence to sort out here there were so
many many parts first of all there were
three co-conspirators you had shearer
and you had her cousin jimmy and you had
the defendant billy so they all had
conflicting stories or at least parts of
their stories were convicting and then
even within each of their own stories
there was conflicting information so the
jury would have had to sort that out and
like joseph mentioned there's that gun
figuring out who actually shot that gun
who actually threw the gun into the
water so it is a lot of information and
i do think the prosecution proved that
case beyond a reasonable doubt but the
jury came to the quickest conclusion and
i think it was the right one all right
we'll see how that case in king as you
said more sentencing to follow with
those additional accounts and here at
law and crime daily we'll be sure to
give you those updates still ahead on
law and crime daily an icu doctor stands
trial for the murder of over a dozen
patients but first little brothers who
jesse smallette say attacked him file a
defamation lawsuit against smallett's
attorney but they're firing back angel
levy is live to explain the lawsuits
[Music]
welcome back there's more legal trouble
surrounding jesse smallett and the two
brothers who said the actor paid them to
carry out a fake crime but this fight
has to do with lawyers on both sides and
jeanette levy is here with the latest
twist in this legal saga brian the
asendero brothers testified that jessie
smallett paid them to stage a fake hate
crime against him and a jury believed
them but this is a totally separate
issue a federal judge has determined
that a defamation lawsuit that the
brothers and their lawyer filed against
jesse smallett's attorney can move
forward and in turn the firm
representing smollette is now suing the
asendero brothers and their lawyers
claiming malicious prosecution
the asendero brothers are suing jessie
smallett's attorney tina glandian
claiming she made defamatory comments
about them in interviews with nbc news
and abc news glandian works for garrigus
and garrigus which is headed by famed
criminal defense attorney mark garrigus
the osendero brothers claim the
defamation occurred in march of 2019
when glandian suggested the brothers
could have worn white makeup on their
faces when they attacked smallett
obviously you can disguise that you
could put makeup on there is actually
interestingly enough a video you know i
think police did minimal investigation
in this case it was it took me all of
five minutes to google you know i was
looking up the brothers and one of the
first videos that showed up actually was
one of the brothers in white face doing
a joker monologue with white makeup on
and so it's not it's not implausible now
mark garrigus who has represented
everyone from convicted wife killer
scott peterson and michael jackson to
chris brown has filed his own suit
against the asendero brothers and their
lawyers garrigus claims malicious
prosecution by the lawyers for filing
the defamation suit in the first place
he calls it frivolous
now attorney gloria rodriguez told me
that the lawsuit that mark garrigus has
filed against her the asendero brothers
and their other lawyers is absurd and
she said that would be her only comment
on the lawsuit meanwhile tina glandian
who is jessie smallett's attorney that
you saw in the piece she declined our
request for an interview through a
spokesperson brian
thanks anjanet back to break down the
latest in the small out saga is forensic
investigator joseph scott morgan and
terry austin terry is anything you've
seen from smiles lawyer rise the level
of a civil lawsuit against them
no i don't think so brian i mean unless
we see some additional evidence what
we've seen so far does not rise to
defamation they would have to prove that
the lawyers actually knowingly made
false statements and that those
statements damaged their reputation and
based on what we've seen so far the
attorney made a statement but she said
it could have been whiteface based on
when she googled she didn't really
basically make a statement of fact and
who knows if she thought it was true or
not but it doesn't seem like she
knowingly made it more importantly the
austin dario brothers would have to show
damage to their reputation and brian as
far as i'm concerned they themselves
have already damaged their reputation
when they helped to stage this fake
crime all right joseph i know you don't
make false statements but let me ask
this question you're a professor
investigator scientist
interviews podcasts uh what are your
thoughts on especially a lawyer being
sued for what they've said in an
interview while representing a client
uh yeah you know
for me this
this is again continuing on with this
nonsense this is what it comes down to i
think what would how they would be best
served is to recede back into the night
from which they came and not not press
this any further because it's a waste of
time and money
and i've got to tell you they're running
the risk right here of walking straight
into the teeth of this lawsuit this
counter claim that's been uh placed upon
them they could they could really wind
up paying in the end yeah it's going to
see how it all plays out and let's go
back to jesse smollett what do we know
about what he's up to now
well we know that he got out of jail
after serving just about six days of his
150-day sentence he appealed went to the
state appellate court which said that he
could post bail which he wasn't really
required to post any bail he was let out
on his own recognizance
and he could be out on bail pending an
appeal this isn't a violent crime so
jesse smallett has been pretty quiet
since his sentencing other than you know
what we saw during that hearing where he
said he wasn't suicidal things like that
now his brother has been posting on his
instagram account saying that his
brother jesse is innocent and that they
need to keep pushing forward with this
appeal
jesse smallett's brother also said he
thinks like basically the noise the
public has been making on behalf of his
brother is helping and they seem very
optimistic that this appeal is going to
go through and that they will win uh so
it'll be interesting to see if that
indeed happens and whether or not jesse
smallett will ultimately end up
serving the rest of his sentence that
about 144 days or so that's left on it
it's going to be interesting to see how
this saga all ends will it be no
conviction reversal will you serve his
time well of course we'll keep eyes on
it here at the long crime network coming
up on law and crime daily disturbing
video gives us a look inside the alleged
sarah lawrence collins sex cult
plus we're answering the fifth week of
ohio versus william hussell the former
icu doctor charged with murdering his
patients
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
trial for accused killer and former icu
physician william hussell continues into
its fifth week in columbus ohio as
several the victim's family members
testified monday husel faces more than a
dozen murder charges for allegedly
giving patients excessive amounts of
fentanyl and other drugs while he was
treating them from 2015 to 2018. his
defense team argues he was providing
comfort care to terminally ill patients
and did not perform mercy killings
whosoever faces 15 years of life in
prison on each count if convicted for
weeks the state called medical
professionals to testify some of whom
worked alongside husel when the patients
died on monday jurors heard from more
family members of the alleged victims
including the son of jeremy sue hodge he
was asked about when he learned of the
investigation into whoso and about the
police interview as part of the
investigation
going forward in time how did you come
to find out about the investigation into
defendant's care of your mom
mount carmel called me
and told me
at first they was down nonchalant you
know and told me that you know there was
medicine give to her that you know
wasn't supposed to and they would let me
know further
in further notice
and did you speak again with mount
carmel after that yes i did and that's
whenever they told me about the others
and everything that was going on
at some point did you speak to the
columbus police detectives as well yes i
went downtown and spoke to them
you would agree with me
but you know that when you gave the
interview to police
in february of 2019
that you you didn't name dr husel in
your interview
i don't remember
whether i said his name because i did
not know his name he was just the doctor
all right forensic death investigator
joseph scott morgan and co-host terry
austin are back as we break down the
latest in the whosoel murder trial terry
the defense went after hajj and other
family members because they have
wrongful death lawsuits is the defense
crossing the line in terms of these
arguments or is it helping their case
you know what brian as a general rule
you have to be really careful when you
cross-examine a family member who has
had someone who has died at the hands of
another so you want the jury to
understand what's going on but you also
don't want them to think you're being
insensitive about that loss so he has to
zealously advocate for his client but he
can't look as though he's trying to
attack them and i think the number one
impeachment area is that you have this
financial connection so showing that
there is a civil suit where you could
win money and
especially if you can show that this
defendant is guilty and there's a
connection there i think it is something
that the defense has to do and i think
he has to do it very carefully or she
has to do it very carefully now joseph
whether it be generally or specific to
this case where do you think the line is
between comfort care and murder and has
husell crossed it
well yeah i think in this case you've
got you've got two choices here uh
either you're ignorant of the impact of
fentanyl which i don't think anybody is
that works in medicine or your purpose
to do this that that's the only two
choices you have
uh when you know you begin to think
about how powerful fentanyl is it's
roughly 50 times more powerful than
morphine and there's been
you know uh witnesses that have been on
the stands
i wouldn't choose fentanyl at all i
wouldn't choose it i'd choose morphine
because only all it takes is just a bit
and it can push an individual over the
edge particularly somebody particularly
somebody that's already in frail health
anyway so my question is is this an
opportunistic killer is this somebody
that's looking at these individuals who
knows that they can be victimized
because they are the least defendable
defenseless among all of us so it's it's
absolutely chilling to me all right only
two options from our very own jsm we'll
see how the jury decides this case and
of course keep eyes on it as it
continues when we come back new video
release in the sarah lawrence college
sex cold case plus a look inside the
journal of an alleged cult member why
she says she tried to murder the cult's
leader
[Music]
welcome back the justice department
releases more than a hundred names of
alleged clients who solicited
prostitution from a sarah lawrence
college sex cult member this as
disturbing testimony continues from the
former cult member claudia drury
defendant lawrence wray faces 17 charges
in the federal case stemming from
allegations that he headed a cult at
sarah lawrence college prosecutors say
he moved in with his daughter who's
attending the school back in 2010. after
that he befriended several students and
abused them for years by extorting money
from them forcing them into sex or
prostitution and holding manipulative
therapy sessions claudio jury an alleged
cult member says ray forced her into
prostitution federal jurors were shown a
video of jury as she confessed to an
attempted murder of rey
i came up and saw you four times i
brought poison each time
what did you bring i brought mercury
cyanide and arsenic
and brought the file of each
each time
and you poisoned me
yes you said yes and my mom gave me the
poison
did she
she was involved in telling you to
poison me she told you
she didn't tell you
she told me
what'd you say to you to kill you
i didn't hear you she told me to kill
you
and that's what you're trying to do what
the heck come you didn't kill me
i don't know i expected to
now joseph i don't want to get your
comment on the cocktail that we were
talking about instead i want to focus on
this one port where lauren spray
supposedly said jury put mercury on the
door handles to kill him and sounds a
little home alone-ish but could that
have even killed lawrence ray
no
no without protracted long-term exposure
you know mercury is in fact a heavy
metal it's it's been known to be used as
a poison but in order to facilitate that
it would not be used transdermally where
he's talking about painting doorknobs
and all this sort of thing and trans
transdermally taking it on board that
she had the foresight not only did he
talk about killing uh her trying to kill
him but he also
intimated that she was painting the door
handles in order to kill nurses or some
other group of people this this whole
thing sounds staged and coerced on his
part she seems like she's under duress
this is a horrible horrible kid
absolutely now terry tuesday marked the
second time ray was taken away from the
courtroom on a stretcher how do you
think this is affecting the case now and
maybe even going forward
no question that rey's health is a very
serious issue the fact that he's been
removed twice is a huge problem he has
to be competent to stand trial that not
only includes his mental competency but
also his physical competency so it means
he has to understand these proceedings
against him but he has to assist counsel
with his defense if he is not physically
able to do that the case is not going to
be able to proceed and we know already
that the case has been delayed for quite
some time when you think about covet and
all the other issues that we're talking
about justice might not be served for a
very long time and i think that with his
health being a huge issue the case might
actually have to have a misfile yeah
we'll see how it goes along and
hopefully his health gets better so that
we can see an end to this trial jsm
terry thank you very much and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you